This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedatam. You don't have to look far to see evidence of narcissism in our culture. I'm an international phenomenon and my name is Miley and everyone does that? No, no, I know that. Snap, girls. Shows over. You can all go home, pack your bags. I have not done a selfie in this glam room. How many selfies are you going to do on one day? You're like obsessed.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维达塔姆。你不需要走太远就能在我们的文化中看到自恋的证据。我是一个国际现象，我的名字叫麦莉，每个人都这样做？不，不，我知道这一点。抓拍，女孩们。表演结束了。你们都可以回家，收拾行李。我没有在这个魅力化妆间自拍过。你一天要拍多少张自拍？你简直就像着魔了一样。
I just need, I need 1200. Kanye West and Kim Kardashian are only the tip of the iceberg. Our society is in the midst of a full-blown narcissism epidemic. It doesn't take a psychologist to see that, but we decided to talk to one anyway. We're more focused on the self or less focused on social rules. At the extreme, that can turn into this narcissistic attention-seeking of everybody. Look at me and how great I am. This is Jean Twengi. She's a psychologist at San Diego State.
我只需要，我只需要1200。坎耶·韦斯特和金·卡戴珊只是冰山一角。我们的社会正处于一场全面爆发的自恋流行病之中。不需要心理学家就能看出这一点，但我们还是决定找一位来聊聊。我们更关注自我，或者更少关注社会规则。在极端情况下，这会变成每个人这种自恋的博取关注。看看我，我是多么棒。这是简·特温格。她是圣迭戈州立大学的心理学家。
She's analyzed data collected from millions of people over the last half century. We found that if you look at baby boomers in the 60s compared to millennials in more recent times, millennials are much more likely to say that they think they're above average. We'll talk about what this means for young people later in the conversation. But Gene Twenge says our culture as a whole, from reality TV to social media, has come to encourage an obsessive focus on the self. I think there are a lot of factors. Our culture has changed in so many ways.
她分析了过去半个世纪以来从数百万人那里收集的数据。我们发现，如果你看一下60年代的婴儿潮一代与近些年的千禧一代相比，千禧一代更有可能说他们认为自己高于平均水平。我们稍后会在对话中讨论这对年轻人意味着什么。但简·特温格表示，从真人秀到社交媒体，我们的整体文化已经开始鼓励对自我的痴迷关注。我认为有很多因素。我们的文化在很多方面都发生了变化。
And the feature that I always come back to is we are a more individualistic culture now compared to what our culture was say in the 1950s. So we're more focused on the self, we're less focused on social rules. At the extreme, that can turn into this narcissistic attention seeking of everybody. Look at me and how great I am. And I'm wondering if this affects not just the people at the extremons of the spectrum, but people who are, you know, the rest of us. You have Facebook and Twitter and all kinds of mechanisms now to tell people what you had for dinner last night, what wonderful vacation you're going on,
而我总是回到的一个特点是，与20世纪50年代相比，我们现在是一个更具个人主义的文化。所以我们更关注自我，更少关注社会规则。在极端情况下，这会变成每个人这种自恋的博取关注。看看我，我是多么棒。我想知道这是否不仅影响了光谱极端的人，还影响了我们其他人，你知道的。你现在有了Facebook、Twitter以及各种机制来告诉别人你昨晚晚饭吃什么，你要去什么美妙的假期，
the amazing things that your kid is doing at school, there are all kinds of ways to boast about yourself to more and more people. Yeah, social networking really pulls forward the positive. It really encourages people to just focus on the good parts of themselves, which in some ways is the definition of narcissism. Now, I'm not saying everybody on these sites is narcissistic per se, but we do know from lots of studies now five or six that people who score high in narcissism have more friends on Facebook, for example.
你的孩子在学校做出了多么惊人的事情，有各种各样的办法向越来越多的人吹嘘你自己。是的，社交网络确实把积极的一面推到了前台。它确实鼓励人们只关注自己好的一方面，这在某种程度上就是自恋的定义。现在，我并不是说这些网站上的每个人本身都是自恋的，但我们现在从五六项大量研究中得知，例如，在自恋得分高的人在Facebook上有更多朋友。
So the average person you're connected to on one of these sites is probably higher in narcissism than the average person you know in real life. And that molds the way people communicate in a way that really does seek attention, especially for all of these positive things. It is really a venue for bragging that just wasn't available 20 years ago. I'm fascinated by one point that you make in your book, which is a lot of this might start very early with a cultural emphasis on building self-esteem and on encouraging young people to follow their dreams.
因此，你在其中一个网站上连接的平均一个人，可能比你在现实生活中认识的平均一个人自恋程度更高。这塑造了人们的交流方式，确实是在寻求关注，尤其是为了所有这些积极的事情。这确实是一个20年前并不存在的吹嘘场所。我对你在书中提出的一点很感兴趣，那就是这很大一部分可能从很早就开始了，文化上强调培养自尊心并鼓励年轻人追随他们的梦想。
And at one level, that statement seems almost anodine, that it's a good thing to encourage people to follow their dreams, to encourage people to believe in themselves and believe in what they're capable of doing. But you raise a number of examples or a number of concerns about the potential downside of encouraging people to believe in themselves and follow their dreams. Talk about that a little bit. Sure.
在某种程度上，这种说法似乎近乎无害，鼓励人们追随梦想，鼓励人们相信自己以及相信他们有能力做的事情是一件好事。但你提出了许多例子或许多担忧，关于鼓励人们相信自己并追随梦想的潜在负面影响。稍微谈谈这个。当然。
So yes, we can see this in the culture. There is this very strong emphasis on feeling good about yourself, the positive self-use. It's captured in a lot of phrases like it could be anything you want to be, follow your dreams, you are special, believe in yourself and anything is possible. It is taken for granted that to succeed you must have very high self-esteem. The problem with that is it's not true from many studies. So big research review looked at this and people who score high in self-esteem are not necessarily any more successful than anybody else, especially when you take into
所以是的，我们可以在文化中看到这一点。对自我感觉良好有着非常强烈的强调，即积极的自我评价。许多短语都体现了这一点，比如你可以成为你想成为的任何人，追随你的梦想，你是特别的，相信自己，一切皆有可能。人们认为要成功就必须拥有非常高的自尊，这是理所当然的。这样做的问题在于，许多研究表明事实并非如此。一项大型研究回顾了这一点，在自尊方面得分高的人并不一定比其他人更成功，特别是当你考虑到家庭背景之类的事情时。
account family background and things like that. You do find some effect that, for example, kids you do well in school develop high self-esteem. But the way our culture thinks about it is you should build up self-esteem for no particular reason, your special just for being you, and that will lead to good things. It doesn't work that way, that puts the cart before the horse. I'm wondering if it might even have an even more
你确实发现了一些影响，例如，在学校表现好的孩子会建立起高自尊。但我们文化的看法是，你应该无缘无故地建立自尊，仅仅因为你是你，你就是特别的，这会带来美好的事物。事情不是这样的，那是本末倒置。我在想它甚至可能会产生更
pernicious effect than that, which is that if you build up your self-esteem without actually the accomplishments and the effort required to build it up in a genuine fashion, it might actually dissuade you from doing the things that would actually lead to achievements. I mean, what psychological incentive do you have to work hard and achieve things that can build up your self-esteem when your self-esteem is sky-high to begin with? Exactly. And so that's probably why self-esteem when your self-esteem is sky high to begin with. Exactly. That's probably why self-esteem is a wash.
恶劣的影响，那就是如果你在没有实际建立它的成就和努力的情况下建立自尊，以一种真正的方式，它实际上可能会劝阻你去做那些真正能带来成就的事情。我的意思是，当你的自尊一开始就高得离谱时，你有什么心理动力去努力工作并取得能建立自尊的成就呢？完全正确。所以这可能就是为什么自尊最终平平的原因。
That on the one hand it could be seen as, well, that means you'll go and take the initiative, but on the other, maybe you won't. If you're already great, why should you do anything? Another example that illustrates this is in the U.S., the ethnic group that has the lowest self-esteem is Asian Americans. Those are the kids with the best academic performance, the adults with the highest educational attainment, lowest unemployment rate. It, of course, it's a cultural thing, but it really does really demonstrate in one piece of data how this idea that you have to be supremely self-confident
一方面它可以被视为，好吧，这意味着你会去采取主动，但另一方面，也许你不会。如果你已经很棒了，你为什么要去做任何事情？另一个说明这一点的例子是，在美国，自尊心最低的族裔群体是亚裔美国人。那些是学业成绩最好的孩子，教育程度最高、失业率最低的成年人。当然，这是一种文化现象，但它确实在一组数据中证明了这种必须极其自信才能成功的观点根本不是真的。嗯。
to succeed just isn't true. Hmm. You cite data in the book looking at Google blocks and the use of the phrase, you can be anything over a period of time. Yeah, so we looked at individualistic words and phrases in the Google Books database. We also looked at pronouns like I and me versus we and us to try to see this more broader cultural view about language use and how that might have changed over the last 50 or 60 years. This is a great resource you can look at. We looked at American books and found a pretty pronounced shift toward more individualistic language.
你在书中引用了观察谷歌图书以及一段时间内“你可以成为任何事”这一短语使用情况的数据。是的，我们在谷歌图书数据库中研究了个人主义的词汇和短语。我们还研究了诸如“我”和“我们”、“我”和“我们”等代词，试图了解更广泛的关于语言使用的文化观点，以及这在过去50或60年里可能发生了怎样的变化。这是一个很好的资源，你可以看一看。我们查阅了美国书籍，发现向更具个人主义的语言转变非常明显。
So you are special. I'm the best. All of those phrases went up, words like unique and personalized. I and the use of I, me, and mine went up. The use of we and us went down by a little bit. One of the biggest increases was the use of you and yours. So a way that the author is directly speaking to the reader.
所以你是特殊的。我是最棒的。所有这些短语都增加了，像独特和个性化这样的词。对“我”、“我”和“我的”的使用增加了。“我们”和“我们”的使用略有下降。增长幅度最大的是“你”和“你的”的使用。因此，作者直接与读者对话的方式。
So all very individualistic language. And it really shows how it goes beyond just this generational shift toward an overall cultural shift that is emphasizing the individual more. You explore the fact this begins right from the point of which parents give names to children. Yeah so another nice beautiful big data data set the Social Security Administration baby names data set. Many people are familiar with this because they'll tell you which names are the most popular.
所以全部都是非常个人主义的语言。这确实表明，它不仅仅超越了这种代际转变，而是走向了一种更强调个人的整体文化转变。你探讨了这样一个事实，即这从父母给孩子起名字的那一刻就开始了。是的，另一个非常好的庞大数据集是社会安全局婴儿姓名数据集。很多人对此都很熟悉，因为它们会告诉你哪些名字最受欢迎。
We were interested in how many babies get popular names. And we found a pronounced shift in the percentage of babies who get, for example, one of the top 10 names. Back in the 50s, about a third of boys and about 25% of girls got just those 10 most popular names. And now it's less than 10%. So it used to be that parents would give kids common names so they could fit in because that was considered a good thing. Now the emphasis is, let's give our child a unique name
我们对有多少婴儿得到受欢迎的名字感兴趣。我们发现，获得例如前10个名字之一的婴儿比例发生了显著变化。在50年代，大约三分之一的男孩和大约25%的女孩只得到了这10个最受欢迎的名字。而现在还不到10%。所以过去父母会给孩子起普通的名字，这样他们就能融入其中，因为这被认为是一件好事。现在重点是，让我们给我们的孩子起一个独特的名字，
so he or she can stand out. And that again captures that emphasis on uniqueness, which is an integral part of individualism. The cultural shift toward greater individualism has had a profound effect on one group in particular, young people, the generation known as the millennials. Jean Twenke has analyzed survey data collected over a half century that asks young people a number of questions to measure their levels of narcissism.
这样他或她就能脱颖而出。这再次捕捉到了对独特性的强调，这是个人主义不可或缺的一部分。向更多个人主义的文化转变对特定的一群人——年轻人，也就是被称为千禧一代的一代人——产生了深远的影响。简·特温格分析了半个世纪以来收集的调查数据，这些数据询问年轻人一系列问题来衡量他们的自恋水平。
So one is to say, do you think that you're above average compared to other people your age? And then there's a list of traits given and we found that if you look at baby boomers in the 60s compared to millennials in more recent times, millennials are much more likely to say that they think they're above average in traits like drive to achieve leadership ability, writing ability, general academic ability. Across the board they say, I think I'm better than other people my age at this and we wondered if it was demographic Just we found out no that it wasn't the groups that are more prominent in college populations now actually score lower on measures like that We wondered if it was actual performance, but it's not as CT scores are unchanged or down
所以其中一个是说，与你同龄的其他相比，你觉得自己高于平均水平吗？然后列出了一系列特质，我们发现，如果你看一下60年代的婴儿潮一代与近些年的千禧一代相比，千禧一代更有可能说他们认为自己在诸如进取心、领导能力、写作能力、一般学术能力等特质上高于平均水平。全面来看，他们说，我认为我在这些方面比我同龄的其他更好，我们想知道这是否只是人口统计学原因，我们发现不是，现在大学人口中更突出的群体实际上在这样的衡量标准上得分较低。我们想知道这是否是实际表现，但并非如此，SAT分数没有变化或下降。
But we did find evidence from another source to see was actual performance, but it's not. SAT scores are unchanged or down. But we did find evidence from another source to see the type of feedback that these students are given when they're in high school. They're grades. And the percentage you graduate with an A average from high school has doubled, which is another way that captures this emphasis that's placed on feeling good
但我们确实从另一个来源找到了证据，看这是否是实际表现，但并非如此。SAT分数没有变化或下降。但我们确实从另一个来源找到了证据，看看这些学生在高中时得到的反馈类型。他们的分数。高中以A平均分毕业的百分比翻了一番，这是另一种捕捉这种对自我感觉良好的强调的方式，
about yourself, because if more people are A students, more people feel good about themselves, even though performance is about the same, and the amount of time high school students spend on homework has actually gone down, so it's not that they're working harder. I wonder if I can push back at you for just a moment. When you think about young people being more individualistic, being more assertive about their own expectations, I can also see this having a really good side to it. You know, if I'm thinking about young women today, I would imagine that young women probably have higher expectations about their employers, about their romantic partners, about, you know,
因为如果更多的人是A等生，更多的人会对自我感觉良好，尽管表现差不多，而高中生花在家庭作业上的时间实际上已经减少了，所以并不是他们更努力了。我想反驳你一会儿。当你想到年轻人更加个人主义，对自己的期望更加自信时，我也可以看到这有非常积极的一面。你知道，如果我想到今天的年轻女性，我想象年轻女性可能对她们的雇主、她们的浪漫伴侣、她们互动的人，
who they interact with, that they're more assertive about the things that should be coming to them. And I would imagine that this has to be a good thing. Yeah, it's funny you'd mention that because that's how I got into this whole generational thing in the first place. The first few studies that I did were looking at changes in women's personality traits and roles and that's exactly what we found that women have become more assertive, more focused on leadership. we found that women have become more assertive, more focused on leadership. And I think within limits, that is a good thing, that we have more gender equality, that we have women who are more willing to be assertive,
有更高的期望，她们对自己应该得到的东西更加自信。我想这一定是一件好事。是的，真有趣你会提到这一点，因为这就是我最初涉足整个代际问题的原因。我做的前几项研究是关于女性性格特征和角色的变化，这正是我们所发现的，女性变得更加自信，更加关注领导力。我们发现女性变得更加自信，更加关注领导力。我认为在一定限度内，这是一件好事，我们有了更多的性别平等，我们有更多的女性愿意自信，
and that that's more socially acceptable. And when I did those first few papers, that was my view, that that was an unmitigated good. And then as my research went on, and I started to look at self-esteem and narcissism and some of the more extreme forms, I realized that it was a trade-off, that it can be a very good thing
而且这在社会上更容易被接受。当我写那前几篇论文时，我的观点是，这是一个纯粹的好处。然后随着我的研究继续，我开始研究自尊和自恋以及一些更极端的表现，我意识到这是一个权衡，拥有一些自信和自信可以是一件非常好的事情，
to have some assertiveness and some self-confidence, but that it is also very possible for that to be taken too far, not just confidence, but over-confidence. So when it crosses into that over-inflated sense of self, which is one definition of narcissism, that's when it can be problematic. I have to say, though, that this might not be limited to the 35-and-under-crowd, where in the midst of a presidential election where there are a lot of candidates who are saying,
但这也很有可能被过分夸大，不仅仅是自信，而是过度自信。因此，当它跨越到这种过度膨胀的自我意识时，这也是自恋的一种定义，这就是它可能出现问题的时候。不过我必须说，这可能不仅限于35岁及以下的人群，在总统大选中，有很多候选人说，
you know, look at me, I'm the best, things are gonna be great under me, I know what I'm doing, I know better than other people, you don't see a lot of careful reflection and self-doubt and caution and, you know, other people know better than I do, you don't hear a lot of that, you hear a lot of bragging. Yeah, so there's actually study that looked indirectly at presidential narcissism. They looked at historians' depictions to their personality and coded these on a rubric that lined up with
你知道，看着我，我是最棒的，在我领导下一切都会很好，我知道我在做什么，我比别人懂得多，你看不到很多仔细的反思、自我怀疑和谨慎，你知道，别人比我懂得多，你听不到很多这样的话，你听到很多吹嘘。是的，所以实际上有一项研究间接调查了总统自恋。他们研究了历史学家对他们性格的描述，并根据与自恋性格相符的准则进行了编码，果不其然，与普通美国人相比，我们的总统是一群自恋的人，而且随着时间的推移，这种现象也在增长。与前几十年相比，最近的总统在这些自恋特质上更高。部分原因只是媒体倾向于这样做，在一个总统选举真正关乎公开表现的时代。这其实并不是关于关心他人。这关乎更吸引自恋性格的公开表现。心理学家简·特温格，我们回来后，简和我将讨论让年轻人
narcissistic personality and sure enough, our presidents are a narcissistic bunch compared to the average American, but also that's grown over time. More recent presidents are higher in those narcissistic traits compared to previous decades. Some of that is just the media pulls for this, that in a time when really what a presidential election is about is a public performance. That's not really about caring for other people. It's about a public performance that pulls for more narcissistic personality. Psychologist Jean Twenke, when we come back, Jean and I will talk about the downside of making young people
觉得自己极其特别的负面影响。当你与千禧一代交谈时，你真的能看到这种幻想破灭，他们对未来抱有非常乐观的看法，结果却对进入成年后所发现的一切感到失望。请继续收听。简·特温格，你描绘了一幅关于自恋、个人野心和个人主义不断上升的令人不安的画面。
feel that they are wildly special. When you talk to millennials, you can really see this dissolutionment, that they were set up with this very buoyant view of what their future was going to be, and they ended up disappointed by what they found when they got to adulthood. Stay with us. Gene Twangi, you've painted a disturbing picture about rising levels of narcissism, personal ambition, and individualism.
当人们对自己和期望的高度评价、自我形象与现实发生碰撞时，会发生什么？嗯，这可能是一幅艰难的画面。所以先做点背景了解，我们从这些对高中生的调查中得知，例如，期望获得研究生和专业学位的人数是70年代婴儿潮一代的两倍，然而实际获得这些学位的人数是相同的。所以期望增长了，而现实保持不变。因此，在某个时候，这些期望与现实发生碰撞。这可能会导致不快乐，并可能导致焦虑、抑郁和其他心理健康问题。所以，我们最近研究了幸福感，
What happens when people's sky high impressions of themselves and their expectations, their self-image, what happens when all these things collide with reality? Well, it can be a difficult picture. So just for a little background first, we know from these surveys of high school students, for example, that twice as many I expect
我们发现30岁及以上的成年人的幸福感有所下降，特别是在过去10或15年里，这可能部分由于这些期望没有得到满足。所以你在这里发现了一些实际上非常深刻的悲伤，那就是，不仅这种个人主义文化在涉及成就时并不一定在帮助我们，而且在涉及我们的心理健康和幸福时，它实际上可能是适得其反的，在涉及我们的心理健康和幸福时，它实际上可能是适得其反的。是的，所以，你知道，幸福感的画面特别有趣，因为
to get, for example, a graduate and professional degree compared to boomers in the 70s, yet the same number of people will actually get those degrees. So expectations have grown and reality has stayed about the same. So at some point, these expectations collide with reality. And that can potentially lead to unhappiness, and it can potentially lead to anxiety and depression and other mental health issues. So, we looked at this with happiness recently,
青少年实际上更快乐。所以，你知道，与90年代相比，他们拥有快乐的个人主义和乐观主义。但在他们20岁中期到30岁之间的某个时候，他们撞上了这堵墙，然后在近年里幸福感下降了。因为过去30岁以上的人明显比20多岁的人更快乐。现在仍然如此，但幅度比过去小得多了。
and we found a decline in happiness among adults, age 30 and older, especially in the last 10 or 15 years, and that may be partially due to these expectations not being met. So you're finding something actually quite profoundly sad here, which is it's not just that this culture of individualism is not necessarily helping us when it comes to achievement, but it might actually be counterproductive when it comes to achievement, but it might actually be counterproductive when it comes to our mental health and our happiness. Yeah, so, you know, the happiness picture was especially interesting because
过去随着年龄增长，你会变得更加满足。情况不完全是幅度比过去小了。过去随着年龄增长，你会变得更加满足。情况不完全像以前那样了。然后是焦虑和抑郁这个更大的问题，我们也看到更多这些问题的出现。甚至在更年轻的年龄，你的高中生现在也更倾向于说他们有睡眠问题，他们有注意力不集中的问题。这些都是抑郁症的心身症状。
adolescents are actually happier. So, you know, they have the happy individualism and optimism compared to those, say, in the 90s. But then they hit this wall sometime in their mid-20s to 30 when then in recent times happiness is lower. Because it used to be people over the age of 30 were significantly happier than those in their 20s. And they still are, but by a much smaller margin than they used to be.
所以这里有一个真正的讽刺，不是吗，那就是被教导“你是特别的并且能够带来改变”这一代人，正在得出结论说他们并不特别，他们无法带来改变。那一定非常非常痛苦。我认为是这样的。而且我认为当你与千禧一代交谈时，
It used to be growing up, you became more content. And that's not quite as margin than they used to be. Used to be growing up, you became more content. And that's not quite as true as it used to be. Then there's the bigger issue of anxiety and depression, and we see more of those issues coming up as well. And even at younger ages, your high school students now say are more likely to say they have trouble sleeping, that they have trouble concentrating. And these are psychosomatic symptoms of depression.
你真的能看到他们感到的这种幻灭感和愤怒。我认为理所当然地，他们对未来抱有这种非常乐观的看法，结果却感到失望。我的意思是，这甚至在大萧条爆发之前就是如此，他们最终对进入成年后所发现的东西感到失望。然后经济形势恶化，向成年期的过渡变得更加困难。
So there's a real irony here, isn't it, which is that the generation that has been taught, you are special and can make a difference, is reaching the conclusion that they are not special and they can't make a difference. And that must be very, very painful. I think so. And I think when you talk to millennials,
我想问你一个私人的问题。你也有孩子，你做过很多研究，探讨教导孩子过于个人主义或自恋的潜在危险。你在做什么来改变你自己的孩子的思维方式？所以我们经常谈论努力工作。我们一点也不经常谈论感觉特别。有趣的是，有些人有时会对我说，哦，你告诉你的孩子他们不特别吗？嗯，不。
you can really see this disillusionment and anger that they feel. I think rightly so that they were set up with this very buoyant view of what their future was going to be. And they, I mean, this was true even before the Great Recession hit, that they ended up disappointed by what they found when they got to adulthood. And then the economic picture changed for the worse, and it became even more difficult transition to adulthood.
我们只是不怎么谈论它。当它真的出现时，尤其是我的大女儿，她知道自恋是什么意思。我们讨论过这个。所以，因为她看到了这一点，她在她周围看到了这一点，她在我们在电视上看到的东西中看到了这一点。并且知道那是什么帮助了我们，进行了一场对话，你知道，
I want to ask you a personal question. You have children yourself, and you've done a lot of research looking at the potential perils of teaching children to be overly individualistic or narcissistic. What are you doing to change the way your own children think? So we talk a lot about hard work. We don't talk a lot about feeling special at all. It's funny, some people will sometimes say to me, oh, do you tell your kids you're not special? Well, no.
嗯，有些事情真的很重要，比如有朋友、在学校表现好、花时间陪伴家人。然后还有一些人们认为重要但也许并不像每个人想象的那样重要的事情，比如获得很多关注和一直看起来很完美。然后对于我较小的两个孩子，认为它们很重要，比如获得很多关注和一直看起来很完美。
We just don't talk about it that much. When it does come up, my oldest one in particular, she does know what narcissism means. And we've talked about that. And so, because she sees that, she sees it around her, she sees it in things that we see on TV. And kind of knowing what that is has helped us, have a dialogue about, you know,
然后对于我较小的两个孩子，更多的是关注，我爱你，而不是你很特别，这无论如何也是父母的意思。然后真正专注于，好吧，变得更好的方法是努力工作，你所做的事情确实会带来改变。但这不仅关乎你对自己的感觉，还在于你所做的事情确实会带来改变，不仅关乎你对自己的感觉，还在于你所做的事。你对年轻人有什么建议？有很多千禧一代听我们的播客。
well, there's the things that are really important like having friends and doing well in school and spending time with their family. And then there's the things that people think are important that maybe aren't quite as important as everybody thinks they are, like getting lots of attention and looking perfect all the time. And then with my younger two, think they are like getting lots of attention and looking perfect all the time.
你认为年轻人可以做些什么来既从这项研究中学习，又将其发现应用到他们自己的生活中？所以，首先，我真的希望大家明白，所有这些都不是为了批评，也不是为了责备。这关乎年轻人有什么话要说，这与前几代人在同龄时的说法有何不同？我们能从中学到什么？我们如何吸取这些并理解，对我们文化的变革有一个清醒的看法。所以我认为每一代人，我是X一代，所以我们也做了同样的事情。我们审视我们的文化，审视我们自己，然后说，嘿，这里有些事情需要改变，
And then with my younger two, it's just more of a focus on, I love you instead of your special, which is what parents mean anyway. And then just really focusing on, okay, the way to get better is to work hard and that what you do does make a difference. But it's not just how you feel about yourself, it's what you do does make a difference, but it's not just how you feel about yourself, it's what you do. What suggestions do you have for young people? We have a lot of millennials who listen to our podcast.
这里有些事情我们想要保留。我想每一代人都会这样做。所以我的希望是千禧一代会这样做并说，嘿，你知道，也许我不会告诉我的孩子他们是如此特别，他们可以成为任何人。也许我会告诉我的孩子我爱他们，我们需要专注于努力工作和结交朋友以及生活中更重要的事情。也许我们会看到这种文化转变。在做了所有这些关于个人主义和自恋兴起的研究之后，当你去参加派对或去教室时，你其实是在心里数着说，你知道，自恋者，不是自恋者，个人主义者，不是个人主义者？我的意思是，
What do you think young people can do to both learn from this research but also apply its findings to their own lives? So, first, I really want folks to understand, none of this is meant at all as a criticism and it's not about blaming. It's about what young people have to say and how is that different from what previous generation
当你看着新闻了解这些性格特征如何在不同的人身上表现出来时，你是在进行持续的清点吗？嗯，有时这是显而易见的。甚至没有自恋背景甚至心理学背景的人也能在当前的政治舞台上看到自恋的表现。但在某些情况下，是的，有时有些方法可以发现某人
said when they were the same age? What can we learn from that? How can we take that and understand, have a clear-eyed view of the changes in our culture. So I think every generation, I'm a genxer, so we did the same thing. We looked at our culture, we looked at ourselves and said, hey, there's some things here that they need to change,
具有这些性格特征。有些人对我说，嗯，这真的有用吗？你只是在给别人贴标签。但我认为心理学的发展历史表明，这不仅仅是一个标签。而是你一旦给它贴上标签，你就能理解它。因为这样你就可以利用庞大的研究证据来了解，好吧，这可能有助于我预测这个人接下来会做什么。所以，你知道，这个家伙
and there's some things here we wanna keep. And I think every generation does that. So my hope is that millennials will do that and say, hey, you know, maybe I'm not going to tell my kids that they're so special and that they can be anything. Maybe I'm going to tell my kids that I love them and we need to focus on working hard and making friends and those things that are more important in life. Maybe we'll see that cultural shift. After having done all this work looking at the rise of individualism and narcissism, when you go to a party or when you go to a classroom, are you actually counting off in your head saying, you know, narcissists, not a narcissist, individualist, not an individualist? I mean,
我在约会，你知道，他倾向于把谈话转回到他自己身上，他喜欢吹嘘自己的地位，接下来会发生什么？好吧，在三个月内，他会抛弃你去找一个更年轻的模特。接下来就会发生这种情况。所以了解这个特征以及其他事情是非常有用的。你把它应用到你自己的生活和人际关系中，决定你想让谁成为同事或朋友吗？我在第四天确实给了我丈夫一个自恋人格问卷。我不是在开玩笑，我希望我是，但我不是。它是
are you keeping a running tally as you look at the news about how these personality traits are manifesting themselves in different people? Well, sometimes it's glaringly obvious. Even people who don't have a background in narcissism much less psychology to see displays of narcissism in the current political scene. But in some cases, yes, there are some, sometimes there are ways that you can spot someone who
夹在一堆其他性格问卷中混进去了，但我确实做了，是的，他在其余的历史测试中得分很低。简·特温格是一位心理学家，也是《我是千禧一代》和《自恋流行病》一书的作者。本期《隐藏的大脑》播客由玛吉·彭曼制作，珍妮·施密特编辑。我们的员工还包括卡拉莫加·卡拉辛、克里斯·班德罗夫和马克·内斯特拉克。您可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们的故事。您也可以在您当地的公共广播电台收听我的故事。
has these personality traits. And some people said to me, well, is that really useful? You're just labeling people. But I think the history of psychology suggests that it's not just a label. It's that once you label it, then you can understand it. Because then you can draw on the huge body of research evidence to know, okay, that might help me predict what this person is going to do next. So that, you know, this guy
如果你喜欢这一集，考虑在iTunes或你听播客的任何地方给我们一个评价，这有助于其他人找到这个节目。我是尚卡尔·韦达塔姆，这里是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
I'm dating, you know, he tends to turn the conversation back around to himself and he likes to brag about his status, what will happen next? Well, in three months, he's going to leave you for a younger model. That's what's going to happen next. So it's very useful to have an understanding of this trait among other things. Do you apply it in your own life and in your own personal relationships of who you want to have as colleagues or friends? I did give my husband the narcissistic personality of an Toriano fourth day. I'm not kidding, I wish I was, but I'm not. It was
我在约会，你知道的，他总是把话题转回到他自己身上，喜欢吹嘘自己的地位，接下来会发生什么？好吧，在三个月内，他会为了一个更年轻的伴侣而离开你。这就是接下来会发生的事。所以，了解这种特质以及其他特质非常有用。你在自己的生活、个人关系、以及你想让谁成为同事或朋友时会运用它吗？我确实在第四天给我丈夫做了安托里亚诺自恋人格测试。我不是在开玩笑，我希望我是，但我没有。它是
snuck in with a bunch of other personality questionnaires but I did do that and yeah he scored low in the rest of the history. Gene Twingy is a psychologist and the author of the book's Generation Me and the Narcissism Epidemic. This episode of the Hidden Rain Podcast was produced by Maggie Penman and edited by Jenny Schmidt. Our staff also includes Karamogar Kalasin, Chris Banderov and Max Nestrak. You can follow our stories on Facebook and Twitter. You can also listen to my stories on your local public radio station.
夹在一堆其他人格问卷里悄悄进行的，但我确实那样做了，是的，他在其余的历史测试中得分很低。吉恩·特温格是一位心理学家，也是《我这一代》和《自恋流行病》一书的作者。本期《隐藏的大脑》播客由玛吉·彭曼制作，珍妮·施密特编辑。我们的工作人员还包括卡拉莫加尔·卡拉辛、克里斯·班德罗夫和马克斯·内斯特拉克。你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们的故事。你还可以在你当地的公共广播电台上收听我的故事。
If you like this episode, consider giving us a review on iTunes or wherever you listen to your podcasts, it helps other people find the show. I'm Shankar Vedanthan, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢这一集，请考虑在iTunes或你听播客的任何地方给我们写个好评，这有助于其他人找到这个节目。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。